so hey everybody had a little Mike
trouble on this one sound quality is not
going to be up to usual standard sorry
okay so that's a good finishing move
[Applause]
[Music]
black mirror is back three episodes man
I wish it was more but like I don't want
to ask for more than that we were lucky
when we got you know seasons that
offered us more than that one go so I'm
just happy to have more so I'm gonna
tackle this the way that I have done
black mirror previously I am NOT binging
through it I know better than to binge
through black mirror you need to take it
in and you need to take some time with
it you gotta digest it you got to think
about it and you need to give some space
before you leap into the next one and so
this is gonna take over the Monday video
slot for the next well two more weeks
after this so this week next week week
after so I have now seen the episode
striking Vipers
so this one has anthony mackie in it so
he is he's the big name the big visible
actor who you've seen elsewhere who
appears in this I didn't recognize
anybody else though it wouldn't be
surprised if some of them have been in
something at some point that I probably
seen but I I really liked this and I
wasn't sure I was going to for a number
of reasons but first of all I should
have had better faith good like there
were so many and this is what I love
what this happens I love what I'm
watching something and because this is
just how my brain works I talk about
this sometimes like I can i zero in and
like I immediately spot the ways it
could go wrong and what I mean wrong is
not like the situation goes badly I mean
like I can see the way the story can go
off the rails and become something that
I'm not gonna enjoy
that's just how my brain works it
figures that out and this thing had so
many potholes that it could have hit and
it died just like all of them so first
up it's it's dealing with video games
and enter you know television and film
entertainment by and large do not get
video games at all and I don't mean that
in like a they can't adapt them way I
mean like whenever you see video games
depicted in movies or TV it's always
like whoa what no that's not how like
any of that works like what that was it
I think it was Charlie's Angels they
like have one of the lead characters
like sort of run through this house
where these two boys are playing a game
and it's Final Fantasy 8 which is a
single-player game but they both got
controllers it's like oh for God's sake
but I should have remembered that
Charlie Brooker who created black mare
and also wrote this particular episode
knows games that's also why play test
wasn't the painful nightmare that it
should have been given how well
entertainment usually handles these
sorts of things so we get a fighting
game is what we get in this one and it
is very representative of komarin
fighting games which makes the sense cuz
honestly fighting games have not changed
that much in the last I'd say guy was
gonna say decade I would say about two
decades all this really kind of happened
is the graphics have gotten better but
like the basic mechanics the fact that
most of them still operate on a 2d plane
and the gravity's just got sharper and
like some of them like function some of
them are combo baseness but like the
basic mechanics of tournament fighting
games really haven't changed and so I
can totally buy the idea that in another
11 years or what-have-you that they're
basically still the same as they are now
just with the whatever the current tech
of the age is and that's kind of what we
get a little bit here I also
up that we see ethany Maggie's character
killing time by playing Tetris because
Tetris will never die and it will be
ported to everything ever that is just a
fact so I totally bought that too so
that was fun
um I'll try oh boy getting into spoilers
but I'm going to have to eventually
because I need to talk about the ending
because the ending ultimately was what
truly put this up over the top and it
was like the last pothole that like I
was so certain this thing was gonna hit
and just swerved around I'm like oh nice
so the performances are all really good
I am gonna just lay out the premise if
by some reason you're watching this
before we see in the episode why would
you do that I don't know okay so basic
plot you have Anthony Mackey's character
and he you know he used to hang out you
know with his you know with his good
buddy and what was at the time his
girlfriend but now it's about it's a
decade plus later he's grown up he's in
the suburbs he's got a kid he and his
girlfriend now his wife are trying to
have another kid he's like he sits
outside at the grill and flips burgers
at his own birthday party and his friend
his old roommate his best friend who
used to stay up late playing these
tournament fighters shows up and for his
birthday gets him the latest version of
the game they used to play because
that's another thing I totally buy that
these series just go on forever they
never die and they will never stop being
made because if it's a name with any
name if it has any name recognition it
will keep going so this then brings in
sort of the virtual reality tech and
using sort of the little side dog that
we saw in USS Callister which means that
they're sort of playing virtual reality
as they're fighters of choice and his
friend has a has a character named
Roxette that he always plays which is a
female fighter and Anthony Mackey's
character has Lance that he always plays
as
and I like I really love the fight scene
in this because I love that it both
manages to convey sort of the their
their experience and playing this but
also like pulling back to sort of that
vet to D to give it that 2d look as they
sort of bouncer do the Big Bounce sermon
and like oh god this is perfect it's so
good and like I mean for myself I enjoy
sure my fighters I've never played them
like seriously I'm not great at them but
Ivan
I've enjoyed them over the years and so
I have a a lot of fun watching that but
then ultimately it goes in the door I
can I would consider this to start to be
spoilers so that's your warning I'm just
gonna talk freely from here on out it
gets to the point that I think and do my
head like I remember thinking I bet you
there are people who use this game set
up for sex oh look at that they're using
this game setup for sex and as soon as I
realized it was exploring this element
of it and and like juggling a lot like
juggling dissatisfaction with home life
not only for Anthony Mackie he's
character but for his friend too because
his friend is on the dating scene if
theoretically he's living the lights
that life that Anthony Mackie is missing
but like he's dissatisfied with that too
and finding something that is giving you
that is invigorating you but at the same
time it's not the things that you're
supposed to be getting invigorated by
you're supposed to be getting
invigorated by your job your family your
spouse but instead it's this other thing
and and it it just it just handles
everything so nicely cooked it perfectly
deals with the just sort of the angst
that comes with mundanity the thrill of
something um being new but also kind of
reminding you of the life he used to
have it's
it has that sort of rationalization that
people I think I want to say guys but
I'll say people in general tend to have
especially when it comes to anything
that is on that has an online components
or whether it's texting or snapchat or
whatever where is like well I'm not
physically in the same space with this
person touching them so it's not really
cheating but also kind of knowing yeah
it is it really is and it it neither
condemns nor fully exonerates any of the
characters involved and I love that
because this kind of story could be
super judgmental of any of the
characters involved it could have been
super judgmental of the wife because she
doesn't understand him anymore what he
needs anymore it could have been super
judgmental of Anthony Mackie for him
turning his back on his home life in
order to chase this it could have been
super judgy of the of the friend like
making him seem like a hedonist who just
wanted to to drag you know Maggie down
to his level but all of them everyone's
part in the situation that we've got
into is owned up to and is presented
legitimately but also like they're all
human they're all presented fairly and I
like how all of it is done and how the
hesitations happen and how you know the
guy slips up and he says in the get in
the game he says I love you and I love
that he can't quite explain the way that
it feels for him to have this experience
you know vert in a virtual female body I
like that he says you know when Anthony
Mackie
you know tells him we can't do this
anymore that he says like it's not the
same with other people so that's not
just a hedonistic pleasure thing that
there is some kind of connection there
but then Anthony Mackie meeting him in
the rain is saying we need to kiss to
see if there's if there's something real
here and I can see where some people
might actually might get annoyed with
that moment that we're like it kind of
becomes like a no homo thing because
they don't have the same
in real life but I don't think that's
what's going on there because what you
get is you get his friend basically
realizing no it's like it is you I do
need it to be you but it is the very
specific circumstances under which we've
been doing this but there's also a pause
from Anthony Mackie if you pay attention
where his friend says no there's nothing
in Anthony Mackie just kind of puzzling
yeah no nothing and like that the world
is in that pause as far as I'm concerned
and that's what keeps it for and again
it's one more pot of old dodge cuz that
totally could have been a oh no it's
totally not a gay thing moment but like
just having that pause they're having
Anthony Mackie seem to question in that
moment takes the curse off it and it
works and then the ending oh my god I
love so much that we do not see the
conversation that happens between
Anthony Mackie and his wife we know that
he tells her but we don't say the
conversation I'm so glad because
honestly I don't want to see people in
that much emotional pain I die I just
don't and that conversation however it
went down was going to be painful for
him for her eventually when he told his
friend hey she now knows that was gonna
be painful that I didn't I don't want to
see people in that much emotional pain
so I love that it stops dead as soon as
he winds up to start to tell her and we
jump ahead and we get to see what it is
now and it's without laying out exactly
how we got here we just realized Oh
everybody understands so she understands
that this was important to him and he
understands that he can't let this take
over his life and he understands that if
he is going to be allowed to have this
on occasion he has to give
her some leeway to pursue things that
she has given up to be with him and it's
just gonna be I probably once a year but
without judgment and with an
understanding that the life that they
have is good but sometimes you need a
little something else and understanding
that and granting that to each other
it's beautiful because all of the all
three of them look so happy it's oh god
I love sorry I guess we're now up to I
guess I'd say three flat-out happy
endings you know and then maybe five
depending on how you count it so with
this good this goes on the pile
alongside San Junipero and hang the DJ
and then slightly more arguably nosedive
I think it's a happy ending and black
Museum which a little bit gruesome but
still like yeah that works so this goes
into the small collection of black mare
episodes that Ori USS Callister so now I
guess we're up to six black mirror
episodes that don't that don't leave you
beaten up not that that's a bad thing
and I fully expect to be beaten up by
the next episode just just I'm just kind
of assume that but I didn't know how
this was gonna wrap up and I had a hard
time seeing I was gonna wrap up in a way
that I wasn't gonna find either cliche
or offensive and somehow it did it like
at the very end of this of the journey
of the drive of this story there was a
sea of potholes and it dodged all of
them and it's awesome
I really enjoyed this episode I'm really
glad this shows back Oh black mirror
striking vipers you seen it what do you
think about it whatever your thoughts
are drop something down to comments
let's talk about it I love talking black
mirror I really do
whole lots of other stuff down there too
because there's buttons and links and
there's a patreon and there's social
media and merchants blah blah blah yeah
I'm trying to make a living off this but
I can't yet so I keep mentioning the
stuff so click on things it'll take you
places consider doing this stuff the
links take you to but also you don't
have to because at the end of the day
you're the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council is it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]